well just a few weeks ago the New York
Times published a piece celebrating the
so called deep state they told us it was
protecting America from the harmful
effects of democracy but it turns out
that most Americans don't like being
told they are ruled by unelected
bureaucrats and that their votes mean
nothing and then no matter what they do
no matter how assiduously they organize
they can't change policy at all so even
as an army of bureaucratic termites
tries to impeach the president for
delaying military aid to a corrupt
regime on the other side of the planet
seeing that is busily assuring Americans
that there definitely is no
establishment agenda in Washington
you're a racist if you think I think
there is this fantasy that there is this
resistance within these organizations
like the FBI and the CIA and the State
Department and the State Department
which in my experience are not exactly
left-wing outfit there is of course no
deep State there is no resistance within
the bureaucracy across the government
agencies pushing against this president
there's no deep state there's no
resistance everything is totally out
what are you watching
what does it mean when people tell you
lies that are so implausible that they
must know that you know that their lies
even as they tell them what is that
about I'll tell you exactly what it's
about what you're watching is the people
in charge losing control why cuz the
internet for all the downside of the
internet the upside of the internet is
you really can't control all the
information on the internet and so the
average person knows more than ever
before and so people like the ones you
just saw on the screen who have had
basically a monopoly on control over
this country for a very long time
all of a sudden they're losing it and
they're panicked they're freaked out and
so they're doubling their efforts to lie
to you to clamp down on speech and to
above all make sure that you shut up and
stop asking obvious questions huh tom
Fitton
makes a living and improves this country
by asking obvious questions and
insisting on the answer she's president
of Judicial Watch and he joins us
tonight so tom Fitton you just saw CNN
assuring us and not just assuring us
scolding us
daring to believe that there was a kind
of unchanging permanent agenda in
Washington you live in Washington what
do you think Oh is there certainly is
you see this with this whole debate
where the president's own political
appointees are opposing his campaign
promise that he was trying to implement
to hold back on foreign aid and be
skeptical of it Andrew McCabe is a
classic case so we just had a document
written by Andrew McCabe come to us
under the FOIA where he's talking about
wearing a wire on the President of the
United States we have confirmation they
were talking about invoking the 25th
amendment to lawlessly remove him and he
tells us there's no resistance these
folks don't like Republicans generally
in office and certainly not the type of
Republican that Donald Trump is and they
oppose his policies and think of ways to
resist it and it means breaking the law
oftentimes to do so we have potentially
in this case of this impeachment leaks
the classified information that ended up
in Adams chefs office that he later lied
about I can't believe that these
officials are so oblivion well I guess I
can so oblivious to the arrogance that
you exude as they substitute their own
will and try to substitute their own
will for the will of the elected leader
of the American well of America which is
Donald Trump it's unbelievable it is
unbelievable I'm just thankful that Jeff
Zucker isn't very smart or else they'd
be churning out effective propaganda on
Cena as it is their lies are so
transparent that nobody is fooled nobody
stuck in an airport has his mind changed
by CNN thank heaven Andrew McCabe is is
waiting to hear from the justice party
whether he's going to be prosecuted for
lying four times about a leak James
Comey stole exactly so so stole stole
though it's all Trump's FBI files to
leak them to get a Special Counsel out
go after him
so now they're paid contributors because
we trust them tom Fitton
thank you tonight and always appreciate
you